foreign
french fries potato chips taco meat soda
ketchup mustard yogurt soup cookies
mayonnaise milk beer wine bubble gum ice
cream pickles baby food even water
bottles are made using corn virtually
everything we put in our mouths is made
with corn in some way shape or form even
the meat you eat is made from animals
that are fed corn with a whopping 95 of
the grain feta Livestock in America
being corn whereas also in candles
crayons cleaners fireworks paint plastic
glue insulation antibiotics aspirin
makeup battery explosives and most
importantly ethanol which is found in
almost all the gasoline in America
that's right even our cars run on corn
it's not just what we eat it's in what
we buy
and how we fuel up so just imagine what
would happen if there was a corn
shortage imagine what would happen if we
couldn't grow it anymore this one simple
kernel is the difference between the
modern world and us being blown back
into the stone ages you call it corn we
called it Maize we knew all about the
goodness of maize corn before America
was America you can't escape corn our
modern society is completely dependent
on corn and all of this corn is secretly
making us sick fat it's destroying the
environments while systematically
robbing us of our money but Bitcoin
doesn't want you to know any of this why
because money they don't want you to
know that the corn industry is worth 86
billion dollars or 10 billion dollars
more than the tobacco industry they
don't want you to know that high
fructose corn syrup is secretly making
you fat even though there's literally no
reason to be using high fructose corn
syrup over natural sugar and they don't
want you to know that corn is the most
subsidized crop In America which is a
nice way of saying money is coming out
of your pocket in the form of taxes and
straight into the pockets of big corn
big corn has worked tirelessly over the
last few decades to keep all of this
under wraps to keep the public secretly
hooked on corn and to understand just
how calculating just how cunning and
terrifying big corn really is we have to
go all the way back to the beginning
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is the evil business of corn
[Music]
you want to know what's more powerful
than big corn grammarly go grammarly go
gives you a personalized generative AI
assistant at the palm of your fingers as
you type for example if you have a ton
of emails to reply to like we do instead
of writing replies from scratch simply
click the reply quickly button in your
email draft and grammarly go will give
you a summary of what the email is about
and give you a few different ways to
reply and that is what makes grammarly
go so special instead of just generating
a generic reply grammarly go fine-tunes
detects it generates based on your
unique context your preferred voice your
writing goals and the app you're writing
in in this case it's this email in Gmail
then just click the reply you want to go
with you can adjust the reply with a
click of a button until you're happy
with it and then just insert it into
your email you can also highlight
specific parts of an email you want help
with click the Improvement button and
then you can use grammarly go to improve
it from there and the best part is that
this AI tool is even available on
grammarly's free tier but if you use our
link grammarly.com jaketrain05 you're
gonna get 20 off grammarly premium you
are going to be amazed at what you can
do with grammarly go so pause the video
and click the link below right now
thanks to grammarlay for sponsoring this
video
around 4 000 years ago corn looked
nothing like it does today it looked
more like a grass than a vegetable
instead of the big lump with knobs that
we all know and love today calm down
today and try some corn or we will
sacrifice your newborn
the stocks just have stems with super
small cobs on them and kernels protected
by a hard outer shell this made ancient
corn an edible it was impossible to eat
so ancient Americans decided that they
needed to do something about corn so
they started selectively breeding corn
to weed out those negative traits while
enhancing all the good stuff about it
and over time the kernels will grow to
be way bigger and way more tightly
packed together the hard shell
disappeared to reveal juicy plump knobs
that were way better suited for eating
so corn transformed from Little stems to
the huge edible calves we know today
modern day corn is a human invention and
all of these modifications basically
remove the plant's natural seed
dispersal system which meant that if he
didn't purposely farm corn modern day
corn would disappear which would prove
to be a problem today corn was America's
first genetically modified crop and over
the next few thousand years quarter will
work its way up to become a staple of
the American diets but we were nowhere
near as corn crazy as we are today but
that would all change but the mid-1900s
[Music]
in the mid-1900s the US government
noticed that Crop Production was
stagnating and it was making them really
nervous with the country's population
Rising they needed to produce more fruit
than ever before because nothing
threatens your world more than a hungry
population but American farmers just
couldn't ramp up production so the
government turned their attention
towards corn even though corn wasn't a
very nutrient dense or reliable crop
corn had one super important trait you
could easily modify it after all if the
ancient Americans could modify corn into
whatever they wanted imagine what we
could do so the US government started
pouring a ton of money and attention
into this one crop they built irrigation
systems they developed new industrial
fertilizers to keep up with how much
nitrogen corn needed they started using
tractors and other mechanical tools to
help corn flourish even more and like
magic corn production went through the
roof according to the USDA the U.S is
the largest consumer producer and
exporter of corn in the world suddenly
the U.S had more corn than it knew what
to do with and running out of food was
no longer a worry so now the US was
faced with the opposite problem how do
we make use of all this corn the
government knew that people just
couldn't keep eating more and more corn
on the cob so they had to come up with
new ways to integrate corn into society
they needed to diversify their corn
portfolio corn is milled by either a wet
or dry process so it's transformed into
syrups and starches that also end up as
ingredients in other processed foods
people eat every day and because corn
was subsidized by the government it
incentivized companies to come up with
creative ways to turn the super cheap
crop into expensive high margin products
and so corn oil was invented cornstarch
was invented cornmeal corn flour corn
cereal and other stuff like ethanol and
Plastics all these things came into
being because of these government
subsidies
[Music]
but the most important corn product to
come out of this was a little Sinister
something called high fructose corn
syrup I see this very often almost on a
daily basis 15 million children in the
United States stepping on a scale with a
weight considered obese teenagers
America's future the number of kids with
diabetes doubled in less than 20 years
two studies out today that draw the same
disturbing conclusion Americans are not
winning their battle against obesity
concentrated sweet
from corn high fructose fructose is a
sugar
corn syrup it is a highly processed
sweetener in my view just stimulates us
to eat more just walk down the aisle of
your grocery store check out the
ingredients on labels and you'll see the
same thing over and over high fructose
corn syrup is the first ingredient it's
in pancake syrup cookies ketchup jelly
even cereal and soup
foreign
[Music]
syrup is one of the main reasons why
corn is everywhere these days it's
pretty much impossible to find any
processed food that doesn't have high
fructose corn syrup in it and this stuff
is really terrible for you high fructose
corn syrup has crept into our food
supply over the last few decades now
compared to regular sugar it's cheaper
it's sweeter and it's absorbed much more
quickly by the body
fructose was initially thought to be a
better choice for diabetics due to its
low glycemic index however high fructose
corn syrup and high fructose in the diet
leads to insulin resistance to obesity
to type 2 diabetes and high blood
pressure but that begs the question If
corn syrup is so bad why do food
companies move away from cheap natural
cane sugar to this expensive complex
artificial sweetener made from corn out
of all things why didn't they just stick
with sugar well it's because the
business of sugar is very lucrative and
back in the 70s Bighorn won it in during
the 70s corn had already infiltrated
thousands of American products but there
was one last industry it hadn't
conquered sugars and sweeteners if
Bighorn could break in and take that
over they would make more money than
ever before but there was just one
problem sugar was cheap and plentiful it
was imported from cheap foreign
countries so why would food
manufacturers ever buy expensive corn
syrup that was complicated to produce
when they had an endless supply of cheap
foreign sugar so big corn got together
and realized that there was only one
real solution if Bitcoin couldn't beat
sugar in a fair fight they would have to
play a little dirty the CEO of
agricultural Giant Archer Daniels
Midland had an idea Andreas had a close
relationship with President Ronald
Reagan and began lobbying to create a
quota on cane sugar Imports claiming
that the measure was necessary to
protect domestic sugar companies it was
the perfect cover story put American
farmers first you want to support our
Farmers now don't you so as soon as
Reagan signed that law into place the
price of sugar skyrocketed and so every
food manufactured from Coca-Cola to
Cadbury to Nestle all started looking
for a cheaper alternative and what do
you know you conveniently had a cheaper
alternative in the palm of your hand
high fructose corn syrup and big food
ate it up now that high fructose corn
syrup was cheaper than sugar or should I
say now that sugar was more expensive
than high fructose corn syrup high
fructose corn syrup started being used
in everything and America's diet would
never be the same
[Music]
today corn has infiltrated every single
aspect of our modern society like what
we covered in the beginning of this
video and because America and the rest
of the world is relying on corn guess
what the government can't let Bitcoin go
under one little blip in the corn supply
chain and we're all going down so
needless to say big corn has become too
big to fail which is what the corn
industry gets more subsidies from the US
government than any other crop corn is
too important for Farmers the U.S
economy and world hunger to be left
entirely to chance so the government
ensures the value through subsidies
and remember subsidies is just a gentle
way of saying the government takes money
out of your pocket at the point of a gun
and puts it into the pockets of big corn
from 1995 to 2010 alone the corn
industry was awarded around 90 billion
dollars in subsidies 90 billion dollars
and it's not like your money actually
goes in nourishing the country like they
want you to think nearly half of all the
corn produced in the country goes right
into ethanol while the other half goes
towards feeding livestock barely any
corn actually goes to feeding people in
the portion that does goes into the most
unhealthy junk food possible food that
shouldn't even be allowed to be called
food and corn farming isn't any better
growing corn takes a ridiculous amount
of water toss that corn fertilizer
constantly washes off and pollutes
America's rivers lakes and coastlines
corn fields to shore the natural
biodiversity of the country and growing
corn is a major contributor to air
pollution according to Harvard air
pollution from corn production kills
over 4 000 people per year and costs 39
billion dollars in health problems every
single year corn is a poison to our
environments it's a poison to our why is
because we never have ought to be eating
corn in the first place and it's a
poison to our wallets and yet there's
nothing we can do but bend over and let
Bighorn have their way with us
the corn is just the tip of the iceberg
see it's not just food that's toxic in
America but our water supply is also
insanely disgusting as well and it's not
just Florida that we're talking about
here our tap water contains a whole
cocktail of chemicals and pharmaceutical
drugs that disrupts our hormones and
causes diseases like cancer obesity
birth defects and lower IQ and all of
that goodness is flowing through your
faucet right now and even if you only
drink bottled water well that could be
even worse depending on the brand you're
buying and we expose it all along with
our personal recommendations for what to
do in our new video on our new Channel
evil food supply that you can watch
right now by clicking the card on the
screen we started this channel because
health is not wealth health is the only
thing you've got and big government and
big Foods seem to be trying their damn
list to destroy your health so click the
card on the screen to watch now
foreign
[Music]